nous accueillons notre terrien du samedi
20h ce soir Jean-Luc Reichmann bonsoir
alors depuis plusieurs années vous êtes
régulièrement élu animateur préféré des
Français et pourtant Jean-Luc parti de
loin de très loin en début de votre vie
il y a cette tâche sur votre visage qui
vous pourrit la vie et aujourd'hui cette
tâche c'est votre identité c'est votre
force vous racontez votre histoire dans
un livre intitulé tu as une tâche
pistache publiée chez Michel Lafon et à
20h dans Salut les Terriens
[Musique]
Jean-Luc Reichmann
[Applaudissements]
Leclerc Toulouse le 2 novembre 1960 père
juif né en Tchécoslovaquie qui a du fuir
son pays en 1939 il était recueilli par
un curé et il a traversé la guerre caché
au fond d'une église en pleine montagne
et la guerre achevée c'est le rideau de
fer qui l'a empêché de rentrer chez lui
il a passé 20 ans en France avec un
passeport d'apatride sans pouvoir
retourner voir sa mère quand vous
naissez votre père et directeur d'un
supermarché mammouth dans la banlieue
toulousaine votre mère femme au foyer
alors elle est très en retard pour
accoucher et elle vous donne la vie en
tombant de la selle du Lambretta
Lambretta c'est un scooter de votre père
au pied du perron de la clinique je dis
que je suis né sur un deux roues c'est
quasiment ça effectivement
on va y venir dès la naissance
évidemment détecte cette tâche de 20 qui
vous parle le visage c'est un angiome
c'est une malformation qui résulte de
vaisseaux sanguins anormalement dilaté
voilà c'est ça l'explication
médicale et à l'école vos petits
camarades ne manquent pas de vous le
faire remarquer tu as une tâche pistache
c'est le titre du bouquin et qu'est-ce
que tu as bu les rouges au salaire de
rien mais bon quand on est mômes c'est
horrible on dirait le pire c'est quand
il y a un prof où j'ai 11-12 ans qui me
dit la tâche au tableau et à partir de
là par rapport au petit camarades il
faut se battre il faut lutter toi tu
étais certainement le gros toi tu étais
certainement le black moi voilà j'étais
la tâche au tableau alors dès l'âge de 5
ans vous subissez des traitements à la
neige carbonique pour faire disparaître
cette tâche de naissance on a carrément
ici de vous raboter le visage quoi ouais
c'était oui c'était très très douloureux
le fait c'était insupportable c'est
l'impression d'avoir le visage labouré
par une aiguille et la peau en taillé
enfin c'est des souffrances épouvanta
ouais quand on est gamin c'est vrai que
ça ça marque beaucoup et puis quand je
reviens un jour je dis maman je crois
que on va arrêter vous suppliez vos
parents d'arrêter cette torture et vous
acceptez à ces jeunes finalement l'idée
de vivre avec cette tâche de naissance
sur le visage vous préférez ça que les
supplices que ça vous inflige ah oui
obligatoirement ça faisait beaucoup plus
mal que ça faisait du bien et pourtant
vous en souffrez donc c'est la tâche
effectivement c'est Reichmann le rouge
en 6e ça peut être aussi le cheveu parce
que Reichmann évidemment le Bosch il y a
même des mecs qui vous dit donc ils
t'ont pas raté dans les camps c'est à la
fois vous subissez des outrages du fait
de cette tâche et du fait de votre nom
et de votre origine disons juive ah
ouais j'ai pris une complète jambon
gruyère c'est ça
quand vous allez en boum vous piquez un
peu de fond de teint à votre mère et que
je me rajoute un petit peu dans le
rétroviseur
alors à 13 ans vous partez 3 semaines en
Tchécoslovaquie chez votre grand-mère
Muti donc la veille du retour vous avez
une crise d'appendicite vous êtes à
l'hôpital sur la table d'opération il y
a un quiproquo extraordinaire c'est à
dire que vous entendez qu'on va vous
couper les cheveux vous comprenez pas
pourquoi et en fait ce qu'on veut couper
c'est les poils du pubis donc ça devient
drôle et là vous réalisez que vous êtes
capable de faire rire les gens j'avais
j'avais 12 13 14 ans quoi donc c'était
mes premiers quoi et donc
ça te fait rire toi et d'un seul coup
elle soulève le drap et scratch mais je
fais non de retour en France vous
commencez à imiter votre prof évidemment
Giscard d'Estaing Georges Marchais Chab
la masse alors pour échapper à votre
tâche et à ses conséquences il y a
plusieurs choses il y a le rire donc on
vient de le dire il y a le karaté il y a
la moto vous êtes dingue de moto pour
vous payer une mobylette vous passez un
été à l'atelier de charcuterie du
mammouth que votre père dirige et là
c'est horrible parce que vous
décortiquez des têtes de porc toute la
journée quoi c'est je sais ce qu'il y a
dedans maintenant en fait non mais c'est
il y a un jour le chef du rayon
charcuterie du mammouth de Toulouse vous
envoie animer un stand promotion 5 jours
anniversaire chez mammouth et là en cinq
jours vous vendez 4 tonnes de saucisses
il me détestait parce que dans le
laboratoire de charcuterie il
travaillait jour et nuit pour
effectivement à chalandais le lendemain
matin 4 tonnes et demi de saucisses en 5
jours et là en fait vous commencez des
études et Machin mais ça vous plaît pas
c'est vous partez vous voyagez vous êtes
d'essayer de voyager au retour vous
travaillez pour radio locale mais le 10
juillet
1994 à 15h15 au volant de votre Yamaha
600 xt vous percutez de plein fouet une
R6 vous faites un vol plané 4 mètres de
haut vous retombez 40 mètres plus loin
c'est bien sûr en lambeaux quand vous
êtes allongé vous entendez il est mort
un bilan 18 fractures 130 points de
suture la rate éclatée comme a pendant
quatre jours et au réveil on voit plus
votre tâche tu as vu la gueule que vous
avez tout est rouge ouais c'est ça voilà
alors vous avez une chance sur cinq de
remarcher quand vous sortez avec votre
plâtre et vos béquilles vous allez
racheter une moto parce que voilà il
faut il faut y aller il faut continuer
il faut avancer dans la vie et la moto
pour moi ça a toujours été un sentiment
de liberté ensuite vous retrouvez donc
les radios locales pour lesquelles vous
vous travaillez avant vous commencez à
interviewer des vedettes
deux passages ensuite c'est énergie
c'est fun tout ça à Toulouse et en 1987
vous montez à Paris et vous commencez
dans la sélection des candidats pour la
porte magique sur la 5 de berlusconie
donc ouais je me rappelle alors voilà
donc ensuite chauffeur de salle voit des
Guignols aussi vous faites des
imitations au Guignol et la brosse à
dents dans la brosse à dents de Nagui
vous faites la fameuse voix off qui
restait extrêmement célèbre la brosse à
dents ça dents
et c'est comme ça que Béatrice Esposito
gloit à sa mémoire elle vous remarque
voilà c'est elle qui met voilà le pied à
l'étrier et elle tient oh j'ai pas
changé du tout ça fait plaisir
c'est à dire que là c'est le début des
amours et à l'époque le producteur et
les producteurs disent ouais mais pour
ressembler aux gens idéal
j'ai comment ça se passe il faut être
beau il faut être mec il est etc papa et
juste avant de rentrer sur le plateau je
suis pas bien je me reconnais pas tu
sais comment ça se passe et je fais ça
et progressivement je fais ça donc tu
vois là elle est mise à pied
là c'est au moment au début où je
commence à me dire je me ressemble pas
donc je ne me plait pas comme ça là vous
décidez de de plus maquiller votre tâche
alors Yves Bigot donc à l'époque accepte
à condition que vous enleviez c'est
c'est Doc Martin jaune voilà c'est ça
rose donne le choix on s'amuse en fait
je dis bon choix c'est les pompes soit
c'est la tâche qu'est-ce que tu en
penses comme ça on aura une petite
touche de couleur
et donc voilà les chaussures jaunes sont
sur mon piano dans la maison alors la
vraie revanche c'est le jour où vous
entendez ouais mais toi tu as réussi
parce que tu es différent tu es devenu
célèbre parce que tu as une tâche
extraordinaire mais voilà c'est ça
quelle revanche voilà c'est un petit
pied de nez mais c'est voilà c'est ce
c'est à une tâche pistache et c'est ta
différence qui fait la différence quoi
qu'il arrive il suffit juste voilà
d'avoir la belle énergie d'avoir le
travail et puis d'y croire c'est une
belle leçon tous les cas
de Toulouse à Paris un parcours
incroyable j'ai dit un truc juste un
truc il y a un petit gamin une dame qui
m'a écrit pendant longtemps j'écris ça
dans mon bouquin et je lui dis mais
pourquoi vous m'avez écrit elle me dit
je vous ai écrit des dizaines de lettres
parce que mon fils a la même chose que
vous
mon fils il a des soucis à l'école ça va
pas il a le même angiome que vous il est
plus grand il est moins prononcé mais il
est plus grand sur le visage
lundi 2 novembre ici même 2015 il y a
cinq jours je reçois un sms j'ai envoyé
le livre d'accord à ce à ce gamin
et elle me dit cher Jean-Luc c'est avec
beaucoup d'émotions que je reçois votre
livre
mon fils est empressé d'ouvrir le colis
de le lire
avec votre petite dédicace merci
beaucoup quel beau cadeau merci Jean-Luc
de votre gentillesse de vos conseils de
votre soutien mon fils va très bien je
suis sûr que votre livre aura beaucoup
de succès sachez que j'en ai déjà
commandé 10 pour offrir pour toute la
famille ce gamin maintenant il fait rire
ces petits copains il est quasiment dans
les premiers à l'école alors que ça
allait pas du tout c'est pour ça que
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu